check it out you're looking at the
kennedy space center where nasa is
counting down to its most ambitious moon
mission in half a century welcome back
to cbs morning's blast off for the
artemis 1 mission is scheduled for
monday morning
a successful test flight would put the
u.s one step closer to returning
astronauts to the lunar surface the
revived moon program has had to deal
with massive delays and giant cost
overruns that threatened to ground it
mark strossman is at the kennedy space
center mark good morning everybody
waiting for this to happen
good morning to you jamie yeah returning
astronauts to the moon has been
america's on-again-off-again goal for
the last 20 years and nasa's had to keep
moving its target gate for a moon
landing now that becomes expensive but
that's also only one reason behind
artemis's soaring costs
it's gotta be one of the most proud
moments of my life i guarantee you our
interest in exploring the moon has waxed
and waned over the half century since
apollo and these images the big question
when will we see moonwalkers again
nasa administrator bill nelson on this
schedule we think we will land at the
end of 25
25.
that's our plan
is it 2025 moon landing realistic no
paul martin is nasa's inspector general
the in-house watchdog for a can-do space
agency that culture of optimism results
in unrealistic cost and schedule
projections and why is that i think for
two main reasons the first is the
technical complexity of the mission
understandable this is difficult stuff
and the second they do wonderful things
but they have
less than stellar project management
practices the artemis program is years
behind schedule and billions over budget
total spent so far 40 billion dollars
the first four launches will cost four
billion dollars apiece the worry here
that level of spending is not
sustainable at 4.1 billion dollars per
launch you're going to be limited to one
launch perhaps every other year and that
cadence of launches is not going to
achieve nasa's mission of having a
permanent presence on the lunar surface
the dollars just
aren't endless the dollars aren't going
to be there last november martin's
office published this reality check
artemis's total cost something nasa had
never revealed what is the price tag
from fiscal 2012 through fiscal 2025 93
billion dollars yes
space flight is expensive
and when you are doing new things for
the first time
it's expensive over time that cost is
going to come down dramatically
one cost cutting move reusing the orion
crew capsule on later flights but the
massive space launch system rocket is
single use
mandated by congress built by nasa's
space shuttle era contractors and at
least two billion dollars over budget
it's currently the only rocket powerful
enough to lift orion to lunar orbit if
there were
an equally capable but
cheaper commercial alternative would you
consider it of course but there isn't
and there won't be for a while
this is the only rocket and spacecraft
that are here and we're ready to go but
nelson agrees challenges remain for a
2025 moon landing a lunar lander to take
astronauts down to the surface and
spacesuits for moonwalking both still in
development both behind schedule by
spending much more perhaps than it
should have cost nasa can do less
science and do less exploration
and it's going to take nasa longer to
accomplish those missions have you
projected what is a realistic date for
american boots to be back on the moon
the earliest possible we see is some
point in late 2026 but i mean i think
that's optimistic
long-term nasa wants to take what it
learns on the moon and put astronauts on
mars but here's what nasa's inspector
general told us either the space agency
learns to spend its money more
effectively and efficiently or those
mars dreams
will become pipe dreams
oh back to you guys wow
oh mark that's a heck of a piece really
crystallizing it there hearing mr nelson
and mr martin go toe-to-toe on those two
interviews thank you very much i feel
bad for mr martin
yeah i don't think he's like the fun
police i don't think he's popular at
lunch you know people aren't swinging by
the office they're like hey we're all
going for drinks come with us we're all
excited about these launches and then
you hear the numbers from 2012 to 2025
93 billion dollars that's a reality
check isn't it it is a reality check but
you know it is expensive to go to space
and why do we explore because we're
human exactly right it costs money to do
something we've never done okay put a
price on that can't put a price on